a version of this problem appeared on
the 1980 PSAT math exam a tetrahedron
and pyramid with equal side lengths are
attached on a triangular face how many
faces will the new shape have a
tetrahedron is a shape with four
equilateral triangles and a pyramid has
four equilateral triangles on its sides
and a square base the answer choices to
this question are 5 6 7 8 & 9 give this
problem a try it's trickier than it
looks
when you're ready keep watching the
video here's how the test makers thought
about the question the tetrahedron has 4
faces the pyramid is 5 when you glue the
two faces together you lose 2 faces so
the resulting shape would have 4 plus 5
minus 2 which is 7 faces and they
thought the answer choice was C 7 but
Daniel lone a 17 year old thought this
was the incorrect response he actually
thought the question was trickier and he
had come up with the different answer so
let's see what happens when we build
this question into models I've built a
cardboard cutout of the tetrahedron I've
numbered the sides 1 2 3 & 4
I've also built this regular pyramid it
has a square base and four triangular
sides so I'm number the phases 1 through
5 I'm going to imagine attaching these
two shapes I'm going to take the two
faces which are number 3 and put them
together so let me orient the faces and
let me put these two faces together when
I do that here's the resulting shape
that we're going to count the number of
faces so there's an unusual property of
the shape if you look at the two sides
which are number two from the two
different shapes they actually end up
forming one flat surface so even though
they are originally two different faces
they now form one the same thing happens
with the side faces which are numbered 4
they form a completely flat surface
and this is going to affect the number
of exposed faces on our resulting solid
so now let's go ahead and try and count
the number of faces I'm going to show
you the figure we have one at the bottom
here's two three on the back side number
four and face number five so this shape
actually has five exposed faces it's an
unusual shape but they're only five so
when you want to answer this question
you end up it's a quite a tricky
question you have a very unusual solid
that results the tetrahedron is 4
the pyramid is 5 when you attach two of
the faces you get you remove two faces
but then you also have two of these
sides which become coplanar so that
reduces the number of faces by two so
you only end up with five faces and the
correct answer is a so the new shape
actually is the same number of faces as
the pyramid when seventeen-year-old
Daniel alone presented this to the test
makers they eventually admitted their
mistake and they said that both 5 and 7
would be correct answers but the correct
answer is 5 thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker this problem appears in my newly
revised and expanded book math puzzles
vol 2 check out that book and all my
other books about math and game theory